dad if you're listening to this this is
a shout out to you so he sends me this
email i said i got to read this on the
podcast
this thursday so walmart versus
the morons right americans spend 36
million dollars at walmart every hour of
the day
36 million every hour this works out to
be 20
928 profit every minute walmart will
sell more from january 1st to
st patrick's day march 17th then target
sells all year long walmart is bigger
than home depot kroger target sears
costco kmart combined
walmart employs 1.6 million people in
the us
largest employer in the world walmart is
the largest company in the history of
the world
walmart now sells more food than
kroger's safeway combined and keep in
mind that they did this only in 15 years
during the same period 31 big
supermarket chains
sought bankruptcy walmart now sells more
food than any other store in the world
walmart has approximately 3 900 stores
in the us of which 1906 are super
centers
this is a thousand more than it had five
years ago
this year's 7.2 billion different
purchasing experiences will occur at
walmart stores
birds population roughly 7 billion 90 of
all americans live within 15 miles of
walmart
you may think that i'm complaining but
i'm really laying the groundwork for
suggesting that maybe we should hire the
guys who run walmart to fix the economy
this should be good this should be read
and understood by all americans
democrats republicans and everyone
president biden and all 535 voting
members of the legislature it is now
official that the majority of you are
morons now whoever read this article
wrote this article this is not me
writing it i'm reading it right the us
postal service was established in 1775.
you have had 246 years to get it right
and it is still broken
social security was established in 1935.
you've had 86 years to get it right and
it's still broke
fannie mae was established in 1938
you've had 71 years to get it right and
it's still broke
war on poverty started in 1964. you've
had 57 years to get it right a trillion
dollars of our money is confiscated each
year and transferred to the poor
and they only want more medicare and
medicaid were established in 1965 you
have had 56 years to get it right
and they are broke freddie mac was
established in 1970
you've had 51 years to get it right and
it is broke the department of energy was
created in 1977 to lessen our dependence
on foreign oil
it has ballooned to 16 000 employees a
budget of 24 billion dollars a year in a
very import
more oil than ever before you've had 44
years to get it right
and it's still an abysmal failure you
have failed in every
government service you have shoved
down our throat while overspending our
tax bill and you want americans to
believe you can be trusted with a
government-run healthcare system
folks keep this circulating and then it
goes into this whole thing right
you read this thing you're like what a
what an interesting point to be making
that to me i'm going to forward it to
you i have no idea who it is my dad just
sent it to me i'm like
maybe your dad wrote that well i mean
when you saw it we said the last
president was the first
business president really when you think
about it i mean most presidents were
politicians for a long time they'd never
run a business i mean obama never run a
lemonade stand nothing you know i mean
not even a lemonade no i don't think so
got it so you know i mean in terms of
understanding how things work and
understanding how you're going to run
something big
if you've never run anything big and we
talked about this on the last podcast
that's why usually it was governors in
the past
until recently that got elected to
president because the people
instinctively knew
that's right that governors actually run
something i mean it's not they may not
be efficient because the states aren't
all that accountable either
they can't print money like the feds but
they they have to run something where
you're your senator what do you do
you don't have to do anything you could
just be elected senator not you just
show up and vote yes or no you don't
have to actually sponsor bills
you don't really do anything you're
running a staff of three four people
maybe and what do they do nothing i mean
they don't
they don't have to do anything so people
know that and they don't have a track
record having having succeeded or
achieved anything and so people tend to
want someone who's actually done
something and run something and
and shown they can do it but a business
is a whole different ballgame as you
well know
and so having people that so you don't
think a senator qualified to be a
president it's what you're saying
uh not necessarily no i don't think so
okay who's the best president we had
that was a senator before
like before last one we had before
recently before obama was kennedy
sean kennedy you wouldn't say was
qualified to be a president uh he had
well i mean his family was in business
so i mean you know maybe a little bit
but uh
it's hard to say he wasn't president
long enough i mean he actually showed
fairly well in terms
of when he was under pressure he did it
pretty decently what do you think about
reading this what do you think when i'm
reading this how do you process it adam
yourself
by the way you were a lot more fired up
last night you seem very poised today
you
you seem like you brought your bet
midnight love this is byron udell ladies
what music would you like me if you
would have heard byron yesterday we
gotta
we almost got kicked out of the rest i
think i think we gotta get that out of
the restaurant
contest we ought to push up guys at a
push-up contest hey by the way quick
shout out we did a push-up contest
impressive yes or no yeah
what do you think about what i just read
um i don't really have any objections to
it i mean it's hard to
object to all the facts right there and
uh big bloated government
obviously whether it's democrats or
republicans have just been spending
spend spent spence spend
you know zero it's actually not a
democratic thing or no exactly
because they've done it on both sides
yeah so both overseas the question is do
sam walton's kids any of the walton
family end up hearing this and say all
right sign us up bro
we're here to help do you think they won
that life no i don't think they wanted
routine they weren't
40 to 50 billion a pound what are they
going to do 70 billion a pop
yeah not even a little bit historically
when we've tried to
goose the business leaders to go into
politics they're like no thank you very
you know remember lee iacocca
back in the day he comes chrysler takes
on a total mess in chrysler turns it
around
or or bob ben moshe at aig i mean
talking about a big hero talking about
an
unbelievable turnaround i mean just i
thought my god this this was 20
of our business back in the day it takes
183 billion out gives it back with 21
billion
five years later i mean i thought they
were done i thought they were cooked
their name was toxic
and then they invited us to the to uh uh
the uh at kiowa they invited us to do a
dog and pony show
and napo is that the napoleon no no this
is georgia one
i thought you know they're going to pay
for a trip to keough i'll listen to
their crap but what what am i going to
hear right
he gets on stage i'm like my god they
might turn it around i mean
this guy was magical seriously
by the way this entire time when he
brought him back he's on his deathbed
he's got cancer he's taking shots and
he's got two years to live
and that's when he brought him back and
he said look i'm living in uh croatia
dubrovnik
i'm by my vineyard i'm enjoying my life
right i have my girlfriend i have all
this stuff that's going on with me
i have no desire to do it they sell them
because he was a former ceo met life
he says i'll come back he says but it's
a 10 million dollar your site says we
can't afford to pay i said listen
i'm like a expensive prostitute i'm very
good
but i'm expensive you want to pay the 10
million i'll come back if not i'm not
coming back they said we'll pay to he
came back
and obviously the rest is our smartest
move they ever did and then and then
gordon bethune continental airlines
these kind of people transformational
leaders they're
very very rare and they don't go into i
mean politics does not attract our best
and finances what do you think it is
that for someone i mean i know
by the way is his volume down or is it
his voice that's down
his volume is up yeah okay you got you
got to raise your voice a little bit
because the audience are saying they
can't hear you
okay what i know that we're gonna
obviously get into topics maybe a lot of
stuff to cover today but back to
uh this is a special 50th episode we've
got a buddy and it's april fool's day i
don't know what we got up our sleeve
well the moment you said it it's too
late i mean we can no longer pull a
prank
why would you ever say it's april fool's
day before
adam you're a comedian you know this
stuff better than i do okay well should
i
cancel the mariachi band what should i
do what do i do on my april fool's joke
jesus well i think people understood
that it was april fools but whatever
well the new people that are going to
come they don't know about it but go
ahead
okay forget about those people scratch
that for the record but uh before we get
into things
uh speaking of baba ben moshe um
what is it that would inspire someone
who has
maybe some i don't know if he was
terminal or whatever the situation was
to say
screw it i'll come back pay me what i
want yeah a million dollars a year you
know what i'm surprised
the guy to do that when you've already
made your millions you're living
just some people is it legacy what is it
that inspires someone who's already made
their money
you say they said there's only one guy
that can fix it
that's the recruiting interview bob we
think there's only one person that can
fix this
and it's you we need you okay i mean
it's a different recruiting style i
didn't know of him before did you know
him before
he went to aig he's a legend i met live
yeah i didn't know that yeah he was a
legend i mean yeah
uh you know joe um um yeah he was a
legend i met life so
people knew of him those who worked with
him that left metlife and went
everywhere else they said this guy was
not a guy that fooled around
he was a guy that knew products as well
as he knew how to run a business anyways
shout out to baba moshe he wrote a book
about his history what happened with him
when he died
on one end he was holding the hands of
his wife on the other end he was holding
the hands of his uh
girlfriend this guy was a very unique
character yeah admired leader very
interesting guy he was one of those guys
if you were in the room with him you
could feel the greatness
like arnold palmer or somebody some
people just have that aura about him
halo around him no questions jake got a
chance to meet him actually yeah he's a
beast
yeah so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]